200,000 علامه تجاريه تشارك في كرنفال
تسوق الحالي بالصين يوم العزاب ومئتين من
تلك الشركات هي لي علامات فاخره واليكم
مزيدا من الارقام
50083 الف من الطلبات التي اعلنت عنها
منصه علي بابا هي للتعامل معها في الثانيه
الواحده في دروه يوم العزاب لعام 2020 نحو
828 مليون متسوق عبر الهاتف شاركوا في يوم
العذاب خلال العام الماضي 60% هو حجم حصه
هذه المنصه علي بابا من مبيعات التجاره
الالكترونيه وفي المركز الثاني تاتي منصه
جي دي دوت كوم ب 20% من اجمالي المبيعات
20% من العلامات التجاريه في الصين تنوي
استخدامه المؤثرين الافتراضيين خلال العام
المقبل لتحسين تجربه التسوق
32% هي نسبه النمو في تنزيلات تطبيقات
تسوق خلال فتره يوم العزاب في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا واخيرا 70% من
المتسوقين في السعوديه والامارات حريصوا
على شراء المنتجات خلال يوم العزاب في عام